INSPECTOR GENERAL OF PURE BEFORE
A REPUBLICAN-LED SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WANTING
ANSWERS ABOUT BIAS IN THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS START US OFF
TONIGHT.
BUSY DAY TONIGHT.
>> WE WOULDN'T HAVE IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
LATE TODAY, THE HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN APPEARED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND POINTED TO A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
MORE THAN 50,000 A MONTH FOR THE
PAST THREE MONTHS.
400% INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SO-CALLED FAMILY UNITS.
BUT THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
PRACTICE OF CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTING PEOPLE WHO COME
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY HAS
CREATED A VERY LARGE POLITICAL
PROBLEM FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
WITH A STORM OF OUTRAGE GROWING
OVER THE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY LAID THE
BLAME SQUARELY ON THE DEMOCRATS.
>> I SAY IT VERY STRONGLY.
IT IS THE DEMOCRATS' FAULT.
THEY ARE OBSTRUCTIONIST.
AND THEY ARE OBSTRUCTING.
>> DEMOCRATS OUTRAGED AT THE
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY AT THE
BORDER WERE PEOPLE WHO CROSS
ILLEGALLY ARE HELD FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AND SEPARATED FROM
ANY CHILDREN THEY MAY HAVE
BROUGHT WITH THEM.
EVEN SOME REPUBLICANS ARE
CRITICAL.
IN A "WASHINGTON POST" OP-ED,
FORMER FIRST LADY LAURA BUSH
WROTE "THIS ZERO-TOLERANCE
POLICY IS CRUEL.
IT'S IMMORAL, AND IT BREAKS MY
HEART."
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTS HE WAS
FORCED TO IMPLEMENT THE POLICY
AFTER A DRAMATIC INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, SOME
CRIMINALS, CROSSING THE BORDER
WITH CHILDREN.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT BE
A MIGRANT CAMP AND IT WILL NOT
BE A REFUGEE HOLDING FACILITY.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN TO
THE UNITED STATES, NOT ON MY
WATCH.
>> ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS SAY
THEY ARE MERELY ENFORCING LAWS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS, SOMETHING
THEY SAY PREVIOUS WHITE HOUSE IS
FAILED TO DO.
BUT THE POLITICAL FIRESTORM HAS
HEATED TO THE POINT THAT THE DHS
SECRETARY HANDLED A LATE DAY
BRIEFING AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> CONGRESS AND THE COURTS
CRATED THIS PROBLEM AND CONGRESS
ALONE CAN FIX IT.
UNTIL THEN, WE WILL ENFORCE
EVERY LAW WE HAVE ON THE BOOKS
TO DEFEND THE SOVEREIGNTY AND
SECURITY OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CALLING ON
CONGRESS TO CHANGE THE LAWS AND
REDUCE IF NOT ELIMINATE
ALTOGETHER THE NEED TO SEPARATE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS.
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION,
OFFICIALS WILL KEEP UP THE
PRESSURE ON LAWMAKERS THIS WEEK.
>> MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE SAY YOU ARE
USING CHILDREN AS A LEVER TO TRY
TO GET THEM TO TAKE LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I SAY THAT'S A COWARDLY
RESPONSE.
IT IS WITHIN THEIR POWER TO MAKE
THE LAWS AND CHANGE THE LAWS.
THEY SHOULD DO SO.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO WEIGHED
IN ON THAN A TRICK OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT THAT THE FBI
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
AS A SET UP TODAY THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING "WHY WAS THE FBI SICK
LOSER PETER STRZOK WORKING ON
THOUGH TOTALLY DISCREDITED
MUELLER TEAM OF 13 ANGRY AND
CONFLICTED DEMOCRATS WHEN STRZOK
WAS GIVING CROOKED HILLARY A
FREE PASS YET TELLING HIS LOVER
LISA PAGE THAT "WE'LL STOP"
TRUMP FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT?
WITCH HUNT!
"THE FBI DIRECTOR SAYS THE
REPORT DOESN'T ADDRESS IT.
DEMOCRATS ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT
OF USING THE IG REPORT AS A
BLUDGEON TO DISCREDIT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION WITH
TWEETS LIKE "COMEY GAVE STRZOK
HIS MARCHING ORDERS."
>> HE IS DISTORTING THE REPORT.
HE'S WEAPONIZING IT TO DISCREDIT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AND UNDERMINE THE RULE OF LAW
AND THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> FBI DIRECTOR SAID TODAY HE
DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER IS ON A
WITCH HUNT, ASKED ABOUT IT LATE
TODAY, PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
SANDERS SAID THE PRESIDENT'S
FIRM IN HIS BELIEF THAT THE